boy Gentry one half of the country music  group Montgomery Gentry was killed in a  helicopter crash in New Jersey on Friday  he was 50 years old the pilot of the  helicopter declared an emergency and was  trying to land when it crashed in a  field in Medford around 1:00 p.m.  Troy is survived by his wife and two  kids  Montgomery Gentry's biggest hit  something to be proud of topped the  country music charts in 2005 they also  had hits with if you ever stopped loving  me and my town the group was on tour and  they were scheduled to perform a concert  Friday night at flying W Airport and  resort the sad news was first reported  on the duo's Twitter account quote Troy  Gentry's family wishes to acknowledge  all of the kind thoughts and prayers and  asks for privacy at this time  [Music]